This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。“绝对真人。”2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the aha radio app apple podcast or
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要收听iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或
wherever you get your podcast hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology well well um a very sincere welcome back I guess and apologies for my absence maybe you haven't even noticed that I have been gone. I haven't posted anything since like the start of the new year. But it's just been a very, very busy time for me. Just some life updates. Firstly, I moved to Sydney. I moved to a new city. Yeah, it was kind of a big decision. I've been thinking about it for a little while and graduated uni and thought, why the hell not? But obviously just like some big adjustments. I've decided that I will not be moving house for a very long time because it's very stressful
无论你在哪里获取播客。哈喽，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，在这里我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。嗯，嗯，嗯，非常真诚地欢迎大家回来，并为我的缺席道歉。也许你甚至都没有注意到我离开过。自从新年伊始以来，我就没有发布过任何内容。但这段时间我确实非常非常忙。先说一些生活近况吧。首先，我搬到了悉尼。我搬到了一个新城市。是的，这算是一个重大的决定。我考虑了一小段时间，然后大学毕业了，心想：管他呢，为什么不呢？但显然也伴随着一些巨大的调整。我决定在很长一段时间内都不会再搬家了，因为这太令人压力山大了
and takes a lot of effort, which I feel like is, you know, well-known knowledge, but I haven't really thought that through. Yeah, it's just like weird, I guess, living in a new city, trying to make new friends, new connections, figuring everything out. So I've been pretty invested in that. I also graduated, a big thing in your 20s, if you go to uni when you're you're in that second decade of your life. Yeah, I graduated uni. So, yeah, also a lot of insecurity around where my life's going, lots of future planning. I also got COVID.
而且需要付出大量的精力，我觉得这是（你知道的）常识，但我之前并没有真正想清楚这一点。是的，住在新城市感觉有点奇怪，试图结交新朋友、建立新的人际关系，把一切都摸索清楚。所以我大部分精力都投入到了这上面。我也毕业了，这是20多岁时的一件大事，如果你在上大学的话，正处于人生的第二个十年。是的，我大学毕业了。所以，是的，对于我的人生走向也有很多的不安全感，有大量的未来规划。我还得了新冠。
Yes, I got COVID. Yeah, it was pretty uneventful. I'm sure the majority of people who are listening to this has probably gotten COVID at some stage, especially if you're in Australia. Every man and their dog seems to have it. but yeah it was just like I kind of needed some time to recover and adjust to my new life but yeah I guess that's why I've kind of been absent and very appropriate for this episode I've just been feeling a lot of self-doubt around the podcast like not stopping anytime soon but in all
是的，我得了新冠。是的，过程没什么波澜。我相信听这个节目的绝大多数人在某个阶段大概都得过新冠，特别是如果你在澳大利亚的话。好像每个人和他们的狗都得了这病。但，是的，我只是觉得我需要一些时间来恢复并适应我的新生活，不过，是的，我想这就是我一直缺席的原因，而且非常符合这一集的主题，我对这个播客一直感到有很多自我怀疑——并不是说我要马上停播，但说实话
honestly honestly I just let some comments from people who really don't even know me I let them kind of get to me how embarrassing I know but it just stung a bit and made me doubt whether I was putting out the wrong content, whether people really wanted to hear from me, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, all that kind of shit. So it's just like kind of a toxic cycle of my mind. So I was like, I'm going to step away. I'm going to plan some good episodes and get back into it. So we're not talking about self-doubt today, though, other than overthinking the opinions of others, which is a whole other episode in itself. We're going to talk about another area of expertise for me, catastrophizing, expecting the world worse, prophesizing,
说实话，我只是让一些根本不了解我的人的评论影响到了我。我知道这多尴尬啊，但这确实有点刺痛了我，让我怀疑自己是不是发布了错误的内容，别人是不是真的想听我说话，等等等等，诸如此类的一堆狗屁。所以这就形成了我脑海中的一种有毒的循环。于是我想，我要退后一步。我要策划一些优质的节目，然后重新投入其中。不过今天我们不谈自我怀疑，除了过度思考他人的意见之外（这本身就是另一整集的内容）。我们要讨论我的另一个专长领域：灾难化思维，预期世界最糟的情况，预言，
Oh yeah, such a good area of psychology, especially in our 20s when everything is sort of up in the air. And we may be adopting this kind of negative thinking style. Especially recently, I've found this with so many big life changes, so easy to expect the worst. Like I've moved to a new city, all the thoughts that kind of go through my head of like, what if I don't meet anyone? I'm so far away from my family. What if I don't have any friends? What if I don't like it here?
哦，是的，心理学中一个非常棒的领域，尤其是在我们的20多岁，当时一切都悬而未决。我们可能正在采纳这种消极的思维方式。特别是最近，我发现经历了这么多重大的生活变化后，太容易把事情往最坏的方向想了。比如我搬到了一个新城市，所有闪过我脑海的念头都是：万一我遇不到任何人怎么办？我离家人太远了。万一我没有朋友怎么办？万一我这里不喜欢怎么办？
And I think thought traps like that at any age can be. scary and it's not only for those who may be anxious and it's not only anxious people who are susceptible. I'm not going to spoil anything, but this is what we're going to talk about in this episode. What is catastrophizing? Why does it occur? We're going to talk about cognitive distortions, how we can kind of combat spiraling and jumping to the worst conclusion and how do we retrain our brain out of these habitual thinking styles. This episode, I think, is particularly, you know, relevant after the last few years we've all had. Obviously, like the pandemic has created an external environment, at least of uncertainty and a sense that we should kind of always expect
我认为无论在什么年龄，这样的思维陷阱都可能是。可怕的，而且不仅仅是针对那些可能焦虑的人，也不是只有容易焦虑的人才最脆弱。我不剧透，但这正是我们在这一本节目中要讨论的内容。什么是灾难化思维？它为什么会出现？我们将讨论认知扭曲，我们如何才能与思维螺旋式恶化以及跳到最坏结论的做法做斗争，以及我们如何重新训练大脑，摆脱这些习惯性的思维方式。我认为这一集特别（你知道的）具有相关性，在我们度过了过去几年之后。显然，疫情创造了一种外部环境，至少充满了不确定性，让人觉得我们似乎应该总是预期
the worst years of unexpected lockdowns, plans, ruin, disease striking, major changes to our daily lives, our politics. And, you know, we see news stories like every day about case and death numbers. And I think COVID has made the stakes so much higher, of course, we are thinking about the worst outcome around this disease because the consequences could be so severe and there's so much uncertainty, especially in the first couple of years. So this is a lot for our brains to process and it can create negative fortune-telling patterns that can really derail us and incapacitate us in many ways. So I thought just given at least what I've been going through, but also what the world's been going through,
意料之外的封锁、泡汤的计划、疾病的侵袭、我们日常生活和政治的重大改变的最糟糕年份。而且，你知道的，我们每天都能看到关于病例和死亡人数的新闻报道。我认为新冠把风险提得无限高，当然，我们会围绕这种疾病思考最坏的结果，因为后果可能会非常严重，而且有太多的不确定性，尤其是在最初的几年里。所以这需要我们的大脑去处理很多事情，它会产生消极的预言模式，这往往会使我们脱轨，并在许多方面使我们丧失行动能力。所以我想，鉴于我至少经历过的一切，以及世界所经历的一切，
it would be really interesting to talk about this and to discuss why we catastrophize and why we have this habit of expecting the worst. So let's get into it. So like always, we always start with a few definitions to get a grasp on what we're really talking about today before the psychology really begins. So catastrophizing is a cognitive distortion that kind of prompts people to jump to the worst possible conclusion, usually with very limited information. or kind of an objective reason to despair or to worry. When a situation, either one that's happening now or one that you perceive as happening in the future,
谈论这个话题并探讨我们为什么会将事情灾难化、为什么我们会有预期最坏情况的习惯，会非常有趣。那么让我们开始吧。所以像往常一样，在心理学真正展开之前，我们总是先从几个定义开始，以便掌握我们今天真正讨论的内容。因此，灾难化思维是一种认知扭曲，它会促使人们直接跳到最坏可能的结论，通常是在信息非常有限的情况下。或者是出于对绝望或担忧的某种客观原因。当一种情况——无论是正在发生的情况，还是你认为将在未来发生的情况——
is upsetting, but not necessarily catastrophic, you can feel like you're in the midst of a crisis and catastrophizing kind of goes hand in hand with that and it can generally take two different forms, making a catastrophe out of a current situation or imagining or making, a catastrophe out of a future situation that hasn't even occurred yet. Everyone has negative thoughts, but for many people, negative thinking can spin out of control
令人心烦意乱，但不一定具有灾难性，你就会觉得自己正处于危机之中，而灾难化思维就与此相伴相生。它通常可以表现为两种不同的形式：将当前的某种情况搞成一场灾难，或者想象或将尚未发生的未来情况变成一场灾难。每个人都会有消极的想法，但对许多人来说，消极思维会失控
and out of proportion to the reality of the situation, to what the situation really kind of requires. And a relatively like modest error, disappointment or a source of embarrassment, can sometimes become in your mind a cause for major fear or, you know, a cause for major fear or despair and in short a catastrophe. So this pattern of thinking can itself be destructive because it's unnecessary and persistent worry does lead to heightened anxiety and depression. It's also really hard to break out of once you've kind of adopted this thinking style of expecting the worst and thinking that, expecting that it's kind of a form of protection if that outcome would occur.
并且与情况的现实严重不符，与情况真正需要应对的程度严重不符。一个相对较小的失误、失望或尴尬的来源，有时在你的心中就会变成引发巨大恐惧的原因，或者（你知道的）引发巨大恐惧或绝望的原因，简而言之就是一场灾难。因此，这种思维模式本身就可能是具有破坏性的，因为不必要且持续的担忧确实会导致高度的焦虑和抑郁。一旦你养成了这种预期最坏情况、并认为这是一种保护形式（如果这种结果真的发生的话）的思维方式，它就真的很难打破。
Yeah, it can really lead to some negative things. So catastrophizing has been linked in heaps of studies to a number of adverse experiences and behaviours, like we said, anxiety, depression, but also anger-related problems, because it leaves you feeling very frustrated, very worried, and if you're someone who tends to project those negative feelings onto others, you can become angry out of the fear that you have of the worst-case scenario. It can also be a tendency of individuals who already have a generalized anxiety disorder, maybe a social anxiety disorder, panic disorder, and of course some of the more severe ones,
是的，它确实会导致一些负面结果。因此，在无数的研究中，灾难化思维与许多不良经历和行为息息相关，就像我们所说的，焦虑、抑郁，还有与愤怒相关的问题，因为它会让你感到非常沮丧、非常担忧，如果你是一个倾向于将这些消极情绪投射到他人身上的人，你可能会因为害怕最坏情况发生的恐惧而变得暴躁易怒。它也可能是那些本身就患有广泛性焦虑症、可能还有社交焦虑症、恐慌症的人的一种倾向，当然还有一些更严重的疾病，
so agoraphobia or OCD. These are obviously diagnosed based on a broader list of symptoms, but a big one is this kind of catastrophic negative thinking style that psychologists and psychiatrists alike kind of look out for when they're diagnosing these disorders. Obviously, you can also just engage in catastrophic thinking without having a diagnosable disorder. It doesn't, I don't think you need to be worried if, you know, you're sitting there being like, oh, what if my whole family dies, blah, blah, blah, what if everything goes wrong? What if I lose everything? It doesn't mean that you might have something
比如广场恐怖症或强迫症。这些显然是根据更广泛的症状清单来诊断的，但其中一个关键点就是这种灾难性的消极思维方式，心理学家和精神病学家在诊断这些疾病时都会特别注意这一点。显然，你也可以在没有可诊断疾病的情况下进行灾难性思考。这不，我不认为你需要担心，如果你（你知道的）坐在那里想，哦，万一我的全家人都死了，巴拉巴拉，万一一切都出错了呢？万一我失去一切呢？这并不意味着你可能有什么
else going on, but sometimes it's a big scientist, psychologist, of a disordered thinking style that might require medication or therapy or some other form of treatment to kind of help you out with. interestingly and I you know this wasn't unexpected but I thought it was really interesting
其他的问题，但有时它是心理学家所看重的严重信号，表明你的思维方式可能出现了失调，或许需要药物治疗、心理治疗或其他形式的治疗来帮助你摆脱困境。有趣的是，而且我（你知道的）这并非意料之外，但我认为这非常有趣，
this type of thought this is always expecting the worst it often emerges when we're children there may be a few reasons for this it can be the result
这种思维——总是预期最坏的情况——通常是在我们还是孩子的时候出现的。这背后可能有几个原因，它可能是
of hypervigilance as a child maybe due to a chaotic home environment a traumatic event something unexpected happening or due to a
作为儿童时期高度警惕的结果，也许是由于混乱的家庭环境、创伤性事件、某些意料之外的事情发生，或者是由于
generally anxious personality if you're a child who may have seen your parents overreact or panic about perceived situations, or if your parents were perfectionist who criticised mistakes, it makes sense why a child who was raised this way may always be trying to predict the worst. If you can imagine the worst happening,
天生焦虑的性格。如果你是一个曾目睹父母对感知到的情况做出过度反应或恐慌的孩子，或者如果你的父母是批评错误的完美主义者，这就说得通了：为什么在这样的环境下长大的孩子可能会一直在试图预测最坏的情况。如果你能想象最坏的情况发生，
you have an opportunity to try and create a plan in advance before that outcome happens. And in that way, you kind of reduce the uncertainty of the situations you've been placed in or of the situations you've learnt to expect. And it's comforting. It's really comforting to think about the worst case scenario and then know that you could probably deal with it,
你就有机会在那个结果发生之前提前制定一个计划。通过这种方式，你某种程度上减少了你所处环境或你已经习惯预期的那种情况的不确定性。这会带来安慰。思考最坏情况并知道自己大概能够应付它，这其实真的很令人安心，
even if it never happens. And it kind of reduces the fear and anxiety in anticipation of a situation or an outcome. But, of course, once this pattern of thinking is formed, it can be really difficult to eliminate the accompanying behaviours into adulthood, into your 20s. And this is because of a concept called long-term potentiation. And long-term potentiation, it shows up everywhere in psychology, everywhere.
即使它从未发生过。这在面对某种情况或结果的预期时，减少了恐惧和焦虑。但是，当然，一旦这种思维模式形成，要想在成年后、在20多岁时消除随之而来的行为就会非常困难。这是因为一个叫做“长时程增强”的概念。长时程增强，它在心理学中随处可见，无处不在。
Any area of study that you're looking at, you'll probably find some research or some paper that will highlight this as being the reason that something occurs. So long-term potentiation is a process involving the persistent strengthening of synapses that leads to long-lasting increases in signal transmission between your neurons. Okay, let's break that down. It's a very neurological kind of term, very biologically based. Essentially, it's like the inverse of if you don't use it, you lose it. So the more you use it, the harder it is to lose it. So the more your brain follows certain paths in your brain, the stronger they get, the more reinforced they become. So how does this apply to catastrophizing? So our thinking style is a part of, pattern and any type of habitual behavior or thought process can create neural connections and strong ones because our brain is basically a learning device. It's a survival device and it wants us to learn what's happening in our environment, learn from previous things and build on them
无论你研究的是哪个领域，你都可能会找到一些研究或论文，强调这是导致某种现象发生的原因。所以长时程增强是一个涉及突触持续增强的过程，它会导致神经元之间信号传导的长期增强。好吧，让我们把它拆解一下。这是一个非常神经学意义上的词，有着非常强烈的生物学基础。本质上，它就像是“不用则废”的反义词。所以你用得越多，就越难失去它。因此，你大脑沿着某些路径运行的次数越多，它们就变得越强，受到的强化就越多。那么这如何应用于灾难化思维呢？所以我们的思维方式是一个模式的一部分，任何类型的习惯性行为或思维过程都可以建立神经连接，而且是非常牢固的连接，因为我们的大脑基本上就是一个学习设备。它是一个生存设备，它希望我们了解环境中正在发生的事情、从以前的事情中吸取教训并在此基础上构建，
to be able to survive future situations. So once our brain begins to travel down one path repeatedly or has a habitual mental reaction to a situation that could potentially be dangerous, it's hard to reverse that because our brain and our mind says we're using this pathway a lot, let's strengthen it because it's obviously important in how this person is perceiving the world and how they're surviving. And if it's emerged as a survival tactic when we were younger to comfort us or protect us, it can be even more entrenched because it's emerged at a time when major synaptic roots in our brains are forming in really formative years of our lives. So once you've kind of adopted that thinking style, especially if you're young, it's so hard to,
以便能够在未来的情况中生存下来。因此，一旦我们的大脑开始反复沿着一条路径前行，或者对可能具有潜在危险的情况产生习惯性的心理反应，就很难逆转这一点，因为我们的大脑和思维会说：我们经常使用这条路径，让我们加强它，因为它显然对这个人如何感知世界以及如何生存至关重要。如果它在我们年轻时作为一种生存策略出现来安慰我们或保护我们，它可能会更加根深蒂固，因为它出现在我们生命中极具塑造力的成长岁月里，即我们大脑中主要的突触根基正在形成的时期。所以一旦你采用了这种思维方式，特别是如果你还年轻，它就太难、
so hard to break. And I've kind of already said this. I also say this a lot in other episodes, but if something exists, it probably has a purpose. So catastrophizing, it does indeed have a purpose and maybe even some benefits at times, but not in the way that it's going to be helpful in the long term, especially when we begin to take irrational thoughts as truth. It can create a real disconnect with reality. And one of the main mental reactions we may have in reaction to constantly catastrophizing is dissociation. So dissociation is a mental process of disconnecting from one's thoughts from one's feelings, from one's memories or sense of identity. It's pretty scary. So you really, basically you feel like you're not connected to any part of your body or your mind that makes
太难打破了。我其实已经说过这一点了。我在其他节目中也经常提到，如果某种东西存在，它可能就有它的目的。因此，灾难化思维确实有其目的，有时甚至有一些好处，但并不是说它从长远来看会有所帮助，尤其是当我们开始把不理智的想法当作真理时。这会造成与现实的真正脱节。我们在不断灾难化的反应中可能产生的核心心理反应之一，就是解离。因此解离是一种与自己的思想、与自己的情感、与自己的记忆或身份感脱节的心理过程。这挺吓人的。所以你真的、基本上你会觉得你没有连接到你身体或头脑中让你成为
you an individual. And it happens because our mind creates a distance from our thoughts and just distance itself from reality because it kind of needs a break. If you're constantly worrying about things, if you're really stressed, your brain actually can't handle that. And it becomes overwhelmed. So it kind of makes decisions on our behalf and decides to basically split or distance us from what we're experiencing by pulling us back into our mind and putting up a bit of a barrier or a bit of a fog shield between us and what's really going on. So catastrophizing isn't just a thought pattern that only happens when we're in a situation where we might feel threatened. when good things happen to people who overthink in this way, they still tend to have an impending sense of doom. You know, good things don't happen to people like me, you might say, or in some
个体的任何一部分。发生这种情况是因为我们的思维与我们的思想拉开了一段距离，并且与现实保持距离，因为它某种程度上需要休息。如果你一直在担心事情，如果你压力真的很大，你的大脑其实是无法承受的。它会变得不堪重负。所以它会代我们做出决定，并通过把我们拉回内心，在我们和真实发生的事情之间竖起一点点障碍或一堵雾墙，决定基本上将我们与我们正在经历的事情分离开来或拉开距离。所以灾难化思维不仅仅是一种只在我们感到受到威胁的情境中才会出现的思维模式。当这种过度思考的人身上发生好事时，他们往往仍然会有种迫在眉睫的厄运感。你知道，你会说：“好事不会降临在像我这样的人身上”，或者在某些
circumstances, they actually create their own negative reality on purpose because that is easy to manage because it's normal and has become so ingrained and habitual. It's a self-fulfilling prophecy. If you expect the worst, you might create the worst because, how could there possibly be any other situation? You haven't thought about what might happen if the best thing happened. And I think people who have this thinking style would rather be in charge of a bad situation happening than have it catch them off guard. For example, you might start a fight with your partner because you're secretly afraid they're going to leave you. And by taking charge of the situation you've created in your mind, you don't have to deal with the uncertainty. And I was talking to a
情况下，他们实际上是故意创造自己的消极现实，因为这很容易处理，因为它很正常，而且已经变得根深蒂固且习惯化。这是一个自证预言。如果你预期最坏的情况，你可能就会制造出最坏的情况，因为，怎么可能会有其他情况呢？你根本没有想过如果发生最好的事情会怎么样。我认为有这种思维方式的人宁愿自己掌控糟糕情况的发生，也不愿被它打个措手不及。例如，你可能会和伴侣吵架，因为你暗地里害怕他们会离开你。通过掌控你在脑海中创造的这种局面，你就不必去处理那些不确定性。前几天我和一个
friend about this the other day, shout out to Meg, friend of the show. But what becomes really twisted and makes this thinking style more permanent is what happens when you are right? What happens to those synaptic connections when your catastrophic thinking is correct, when your worst case scenario is correct? What happens then? What happens is that it confirms everything that you've already kind of believed to be true. It confirms that this thinking style is the best one to have, you know, oh, if I didn't catastrophize, if I didn't expect the worst, what would be happening to me right now? And you think that that would make you happy, right? You know, you made a plan for this, you knew this could happen. Surely you'd be prepared and can
朋友聊过这个，向梅格（节目的朋友）致敬。但是，真正扭曲并使这种思维方式变得更加永久的是：当你猜对时会发生什么？当你的灾难性思考是正确的、当你的最到头情况是正确的时候，那些突触连接会发生什么？那时会发生什么？发生的情况是，它证实了你一直以来认为真实的一切。它证实了这种思维方式是最好的思维方式，你知道的，“哦，如果我没有把事情灾难化，如果我没有预期最糟糕的情况，我现在会变成什么样？”你以为这会让你快乐，对吧？你知道的，你为此做好了计划，你知道这可能会发生。你肯定会觉得自己有准备并且能够
handle it. It's like, no one's going to say, or you were wrong, because you were right. And obviously that's so rarely the case, which is a massive thing, the negative situations we think of, the worst case scenarios, that prophesizing, it's so rarely that it comes true. But also, it's really unlikely that the negative thinking you've done beforehand can even help, which is why this spiral can only ever provide short-term comfort. So what my friend and I were discussing was that by the time the worst-case scenario kind of rolls around, you're so emotionally drained that whatever the outcome is, you aren't even prepared to deal with it. You're frustrated, you're anxious, you have brain fog, you're overwhelmed because you have already exhausted your mental energy
应付它。这就好比，没有人会说，或者你错了，因为你确实猜对了。而显然这种情况少之又少，这是一个巨大的重点——我们想到的那些消极情况、那些最坏的情况、那种预言，成真的几率实在太低了。不仅如此，你事先所做的消极思考也几乎不可能帮到什么忙，这就是为什么这种焦虑螺旋永远只能提供短期的安慰。所以我和我朋友讨论的是，等到最坏的情况真的降临的时候，你的情感已经被榨干了，无论结果如何，你甚至都没有准备好去应付它。你感到沮丧、焦虑、大脑一片混沌、不堪重负，因为你已经在各个方面、各个部门耗尽了你的精神能量，只为了提前解决这个问题。所以它根本帮不到你。此外，灾难化思维在当下可能会让人感到安慰，但它并不能给你任何答案。在这方面让我感触特别深的一个领域是，我对死亡有一种奇怪的恐惧。这是触发我焦虑的一个巨大导火索。我从小就这样。每当我压力极大或极度疲惫时，我总是会为此担忧。我到了一个地步，我意识到无论怎么思考都无法解开答案。这需要大量的思考。
across all faculties, all departments, trying to solve the problem in advance. So it doesn't really help you. Also, catastrophizing may feel comforting in the moment, but it doesn't give you any answers. And an area where this feels particularly relevant to me is I have this weird fear of death. And this is a massive trigger for me. I've had it since I was a child. I always worry about it when I'm really stressed or really tired. And I got to the point where I realized that no amount of thinking was going to uncover an answer. It was a lot of thinking. something I could predict and even if I did accidentally it would never really be confirmed until I died and it led to intrusive thought intrusive thought because the catastrophizing was making me so
这不是我可以预测的事情，即使我偶然猜中了，在我死之前也永远不会真正得到证实，这导致了侵入性想法。由于灾难化思维让我变得如此
depressed and anxious it was fucking terrible I was just thinking about it all the time I was thinking about what could the worst case scenario be and I can't change that even if I was right there's nothing I could do so how do we get out of this what strategies do we need to learn in our 20s in our very important decade of life, probably even more important than when you were younger because you get a chance to unlearn all those negative behaviours. But what do we need to do to make sure we don't always expect the worst in every situation? You know, you could go to therapy. We can talk about therapy, but that's so intangible, I think. And I feel like it's not really something to get into in this episode. Everyone knows the benefits of therapy, but I'm obviously not a psychologist, so I can't sit here
抑郁和焦虑，这他妈太糟糕了。我满脑子都在想这个。我一直在想最坏的情况会是什么，而我无法改变这一点，即使我猜对了，我也无能为力。那么我们该如何摆脱困境呢？在20多岁、在我们人生中这个非常重要的十年里，我们究竟需要学习什么策略——可能比你年轻时还要重要，因为你有机会改掉所有那些负面行为。但为了确保我们不会在每一种情况下都总是预期最坏的情况，我们到底需要做些什么？你知道的，你可以去看心理医生。我们可以谈谈心理治疗，但我认为这太抽象了。而且我觉得这并不是这一集真正应该深入探讨的内容。每个人都知道心理治疗的好处，但我显然不是心理学家，所以我不能坐在这里
and give you all the strategies that you need. But let's look at some more practical steps for when you're in the spiral. So six tips to kind of accomplish this, you know, breaking away from this thinking style might be some of the following. So acknowledging that unpleasant things happen is number one. This is a massive kind of philosophy
把你需要的所有策略都讲给你听。不过，让我们来看看当你陷入这种思维螺旋时一些更切实可行的步骤。因此，实现这一目标的六个技巧，（你知道的）摆脱这种思维方式可能包括以下几点。首先，承认不愉快的事情会发生是第一步。这是一种非常宏大的哲学，
that's taught throughout any mental health area or profession. Life is full of challenges. And you have good days and you have bad days. And just because one day is bad does not mean that all days will be bad. And acknowledging that sometimes you're going to be unprepared and accepting that is perhaps a lot better than needing to plan to know what every single outcome could be and thinking about what you would do. Secondly, it's important to recognize when thoughts are irrational. Catastrophizing often follows a distinct pattern. So a person will start with a thought.
它贯穿于任何心理健康领域或职业。生活充满挑战。你有美好的一天，也会有糟糕的一天。仅仅因为某一天糟糕，并不意味着所有的日子都会糟糕。而且承认有时你会毫无准备并接受这一点，可能远比非得去计划、去知道每一种可能的结果会是什么并思考你会怎么做好得多。其次，认识到什么时候想法是不理智的，这一点至关重要。灾难化思维通常遵循一个清晰的模式。一个人会从一个想法开始。
Then they will expand on that thought with worry and anxiety. when a person learns to recognize not just the first thought but the second thought, the one where we expand on it, the better equipped to handle this catastrophizing kind of spiral that we go into. If you think, oh my God, but what if we drove, what if when I was driving, I crashed and I died and I killed someone on the road, you know, it's okay to have that thought. You can think that, but you don't have to have the accompanying anxiety. You can kind of just acknowledge it. third step well not really step tip just saying stop to cease the repetitive catastrophic thoughts a person may have to say it out loud in their head or just to say stop i don't want to think about this no more i'm in
然后他们会带着担忧和焦虑去放大这个想法。当一个人学会认识到的不仅是第一个想法，还有第二个想法——也就是我们对它进行放大的那个想法——他们就越有能力应对我们陷入的那种灾难化思维螺旋。如果你在想，“天哪，但是万一我们开车，万一我开车时发生车祸然后死了，我还把路上的人给撞死了呢”（你知道的），有这种想法是正常的。你可以这么想，但你不需要伴随那种焦虑。你基本上只需要承认它就行了。第三步——其实也不是步骤，只是个小贴士——就是说“停”，为了制止那些反复出现的灾难性想法，一个人可能需要在脑海里大声说出来，或者干脆说“停，我不想再想这个了。我掌控着一切，
control i'm in control of what i choose goes through my brain and these words can keep the stream of thoughts from continuing and help you change the course of your thinking another one that i really like is thinking about another outcome. So instead of thinking about a negative outcome, think about the best outcome, the most positive outcome, and what that would mean. It's just as likely that the best outcome
我能掌控进入我大脑的东西。”这些话可以阻止源源不断的思绪继续下去，并帮助你改变思维的走向。另一个我真的很喜欢的技巧是：思考另一种结果。与其去想一个消极的结果，不如去想最好的结果、最积极的结果，以及那意味着什么。最好结果发生的概率
could happen as the worst. So visualising what you think the best outcome could be might actually help you problem solve to get to that point. Number five is offering positive affirmations. It seems really simple, but I really like this. When it comes to catastrophic thinking, a person has to believe in themselves and that they could have become whatever happens. And that kind of reduces your tendency to fear the worst. They may wish to repeat a positive affirmation to themselves on a daily basis or something along those lines.
其实和最坏结果发生的概率是一样的。所以，把你能想到的最好的结果可视化，实际上可能会帮助你解决问题，从而达到那个目标。第五个是给予积极的肯定。这看起来真的很简单，但我真的很喜欢。当谈到灾难性思维时，一个人必须相信自己，相信无论发生什么，他们都能够应付。这可以减少你对最坏情况的恐惧。他们可能希望每天对自己重复一次积极的肯定，或者类似的话。
Finally, the sixth kind of solution is one that I think makes its way into every fucking article ever about any kind of thought. or thinking style or situation that has to do with your psychology and mental health. And that's practicing excellent self-care. So this is the explanation that this article gave. I'm going to read it out first and then I'm going to discuss it because I have opinions, obviously. This is why I have a podcast. But practicing excellent self-care, I think catastrophic thoughts are more likely to take over when you are stressed and when you're tired. So getting enough rest and engaging in like stressful living.
最后，第六种解决方法，我认为它出现在了每一篇他妈的关于任何想法、
techniques like exercise or meditation or journaling, it can make you feel better. And I have a slight problem with this. I think that self-care is the serpent of the mental health community or culture. And I wrote an article about this once, but I think self-care is actually an accessory. It's not the cure. And I do think we need to stop pushing kind of like a self-care narrative for every fucking issue in our lives. You can't cure your anxiety by doing a face mask or your catastrophic thinking by eating superfoods. Also, there are just so many instances in which what we're going through prevents self-care habits, and I think it's such a simple blanket solution that is so insidious.
思维方式或与心理和精神健康有关的情况的文章中。那就是：践行出色的自我关爱。所以这是这篇文章给出的解释。我先把它读出来，然后我再讨论它，因为我显然有自己的看法。这就是为什么我有一个播客。但践行出色的自我关爱——我认为当你感到压力大和疲劳时，灾难性的想法更有可能占据上风。所以获得充足的休息并参与（诸如运动、冥会或写日记之类）压力管理的技巧，可以让你感觉更好。而我对这一点有一点小小的意见。我认为自我关爱是心理健康社群或文化中的“毒蛇”。我曾经写过一篇文章专门谈这个，但我认为自我关爱其实只是一种配饰。它不是解药。而且我确实认为我们应该停止把自我关爱这种说辞强加给我们生活中他妈的每一个问题上。你不可能通过敷面膜来治愈焦虑，也不可能通过吃超级食物来治愈你的灾难性思维。此外，有太多的情况下，我们正在经历的事情恰恰阻碍了自我关爱习惯的养成，而且我认为这是一种如此简单、如此隐蔽的一刀切的解决方案。
You see it everywhere on Instagram, from mental health professionals to health care professionals from our friends, from our workplaces, like emails being like, how are you practicing self-care at the moment? Like, how come you don't ask us how you're going to provide better mental health care? for our workplace. Like, self-care makes it, like, all of your, all your kind of problem. And it's like, you know, you could just be better if you just spent more money on things that society is telling you you need to feel good about yourself.
你到处都能在Instagram上看到它，从心理健康专家到医疗保健专家、从我们的朋友、从我们的工作场所，比如发邮件问：“你目前是怎么践行自我关爱的？”就像，你们怎么不问问你们将如何为我们的工作场所提供更好的心理健康关怀呢？自我关爱让它感觉好像，你所有的、所有的这种问题都是你自己的事。这就好像，你知道的，如果你只是把更多的钱花在社会告诉你需要用来感觉良好的东西上，你就会变得更好。
You could just spend more money on skincare and healthy foods and gym memberships and meditation apps and yoga. Like, it's ridiculous. And I think if catastrophic thinking reacted that easily and positively to self-care, it really wouldn't be a problem, would it? Anyhow, there's a random tangent. about my hatred of the self-care philosophy. I really don't like it.
你只要花更多的钱在护肤品、健康食品、健身房会员卡、冥想应用程序和瑜伽上就可以了。这太荒谬了。而且我认为，如果灾难性思维对自我关爱的反应那么容易、那么积极的话，它根本就不会是一个问题，对吧？不管怎样，这是一个随机的分支，
I think it's so insidious, and I hate the way it makes people feel that the reason they're not doing well is because they're not taking care of themselves when they might be trying. And even if they can't take care of themselves, isn't that a bigger problem that we should be helping them with rather than telling them to get enough sleep?
关于我对自我关爱哲学的厌恶。我真的很讨厌它。我认为它是如此隐蔽，我讨厌它让人们觉得他们过得不好是因为他们没有照顾好自己，而他们明明可能已经在努力了。而且，即使他们无法照顾自己，难道这不是一个更严重的问题吗？我们本应该去帮助他们，而不是告诉他们要睡个好觉。
Like, what if you have insomnia? Come on, wake up people. But back to what we're actually talking here about. I think next time you have a kind of a what-if, thought, remember to tell yourself that you can handle anything that comes your way. Try to think about the worst case scenario and whether you'll handle it. Yeah, you can be realistic. And you probably can. You probably can handle it. But then also think about the best case scenario. That's just as likely to happen. And ask yourself whether you truly believe this what if thought will actually come true.
比如，如果你有失眠症怎么办？行了，大家醒醒吧。但回到我们今天实际要讨论的话题上来。我想，下次当你产生“万一”的想法时，记得告诉自己：你能应付迎面而来的任何事情。试着想想最坏的情况，以及你是否能够应付它。是的，你可以现实一点。而且你大概也确实能。你大概能应付得了。但同时也要想想最好的情况。那同样很有可能发生。并问问自己：你是否真的相信这个“万一”的想法会成真？
How many times have you thought something would happen and it never did? How many moments and minutes have you spent worrying about an outcome that just never emerged? Because it's so unlikely that we're going to get it right when not mine readers. We can't predict the future. And ask yourself, what's truly bothering you? Was it really that comment your boss said or are you simply unhappy at your job and afraid to leave? Is your partner really going to leave you? Are you really going to die in a car accident or are you just a little bit tired and get to the root of the problem?
有多少次你以为某事会发生，但它却根本没有发生？你有多少时刻和分钟是在为一个最终根本没有出现的结局而担忧？因为我们根本不是读心者，我们不可能把事情都猜对。我们无法预测未来。并问问自己：到底是什么在真正困扰着你？真的是你老板说的那句话吗，还是你只是对自己的工作不满意又不敢辞职？你的伴侣真的会离开你吗？你真的会在车祸中丧生，还是你只是有点累了？去找到问题的根源。
I think what if thinking is a distraction to remove us from the present moment? It's a tool our brain uses to provide comfort when we're stressed and we're anxious about things that we can't predict. This can kind of help you slow your thoughts down and get back into reality if you kind of rationalize it. And remember that very few, if any, if any, of our negative thoughts come to pass. This is so important in our 20s when our thinking patterns. this is when they become ingrained for life and so much is up in the air. We haven't had enough experiences to know that things will turn out okay. Our brains are still developing people.
我认为“万一”的想法其实是一种干扰，把我们从当下抽离出来。它是我们的大脑在面对我们无法预测的事情感到压力和焦虑时，用来提供安慰的一种工具。如果你理性看待它，这可以帮助你放慢思绪，回到现实中来。并记住，我们极少（如果有的话，哪怕有一点点）消极想法会真正成为现实。这在我们的20多岁时非常重要，因为在这个时期，我们的思维模式
They're still developing into our 20s. You know, I think it's like not until you're 25, 26 is your frontal lobe fully developed. And even then synaptic plasticity means that there's so many things that we can take into our own hands and change about how our brains work. And yeah, I think it's just easier, though, at this time, to create healthier thinking patterns than waiting until you're kind of an old dog trying to learn new tricks. And rather than always expecting the worst for the rest of your life, a very quick, informative episode today. Yeah, I was really inspired by this conversation my friend and I were having. She came and visited me in Sydney, and we were just kind of talking about that. She was interviewing for a job, and obviously I had just moved.
正在为这一生定型，而且有太多的事情悬而未决。我们还没有经历过足够多的事情来确信一切都会好起来。我们的脑子还在发育呢，各位。我们的前额叶皮层直到20多岁还在继续发育。你知道，我想大概要到25、26岁时，你的前额叶皮层才完全发育成熟。即便如此，突触可塑性意味着我们仍然有很多事情可以自己掌握，并改变我们大脑的工作方式。而且，是的，我觉得在这个时期，养成更健康的思维方式总归要比等到你老了再去学什么新把戏要容易得多。与其在余生中总是预期最糟糕的情况……今天的节目非常简短且充满信息量。是的，我真的深受我和我朋友谈话的启发。她来悉尼看望我，我们就聊到了这些。她当时正在面试工作，而我显然刚刚搬家。
So when the in those kind of moments where everything is quite uncertain and you're on very shaky foundations, obviously we were both finding ourselves overthinking quite a bit about everything that could go wrong. And so far it's turned out pretty well. Everything's turned out all right. And it's something that I get into all the time. I really can't stop it. And it really gets to me when I don't want to be thinking the worst when I know that the worst
所以，在那些一切都非常不确定、脚下基础摇摇欲坠的时刻，显然我们俩都发现自己对所有可能出错的事情进行了相当多的过度思考。到目前为止，结果还算不错。一切都好。这也是我经常陷入的一种状态。我真的无法停止它。当我明明知道最坏的情况不会发生，但我并不想去想最坏的情况，而我的大脑却偏偏要一而再再而三地这么做时，这真的让我很崩溃。所以，如果你也是这种人，希望这一集能为你提供一些可以培养的技能，给你一些思考的东西，并让你明白你为什么会这样做。这其实真的不是你的错。它有着各种各样的根源，但没有人会有一天突然决定：“哦，我要他妈的把我的生活以及所有可能出错的事情彻底解剖一番。”因为这听起来难道不像是一个梦想、像是在公园里散步一样轻松吗？不管怎样，我下周会发布另一集关于争吵和人际冲突的播客。希望你能从中获得乐趣。
isn't going to happen, but my brain just keeps on doing it. So if you're one of those people, hopefully this episode gave you some skills to develop, gave you some things to think about, gave you some understanding about why you do it. And that's really not your fault. It comes from so many places, but no one wakes up one day and decides, oh, I'm going to like fucking analyze the shit out of my life and everything that could possibly go wrong. Because doesn't that sound like a dream, like a walk in the park? But anyhow, I'm posting another episode next week about fighting and interpersonal conflict. Hopefully you get a kick out of it.
是的，非常令人兴奋的时期。我很期待播客的第二季，并投入到更多内容中。一如既往，如果你对任何你想让我研究并发布的节目有什么建议，随时在我的Instagram上给我发私信。账号叫20 Psychology Podcast。你也可以看看我的Reels，因为。是的，我确实制作Instagram Reels，因为我想获得更多的粉丝，这样我们就可以建立一个更大的社区，我们可以分享我们的想法，我们可以分享那些发生在
Yeah, very exciting times. I'm keen for kind of like season two of the podcast and to jump into some more content. As always, if you have any suggestions for episodes that you kind of want me to research and put out there, just shoot me a message on my Instagram. It's called 20 Psychology Podcast. You can also watch my reels because. yeah, I do make Instagram reels because I want to get more followers because I want to have a bigger community so we can share our thoughts and we can share all the fucked up shape happening
20多岁时的所有狗血事情，当然还有所有美好的事情——比如毕业、搬家、坠入爱河，所有这些美丽美妙的事情。谢谢你们的支持。谢谢你们的收听。我老是这么问，但如果你觉得愿意留下评论，Spotify和Apple都接受对播客的评价，它们真的很有帮助，能让这种音频、这个社群、我分享的节目触达更多人。如果你觉得这可能对某人有用——也许你觉得没有，如果是那样的话也没关系——那就为你真正喜欢的另一个播客留个好评吧，因为我保证这会点亮某人的一天。无论你身处世界的哪个角落，祝你有美好的一周、美好的周末，谢谢收听。我们下周见。
in our 20s and all the good stuff as well like graduating like moving like pulling in love all of those beautiful wonderful things. So thanks for your support. Thanks for listening. I always ask this but if you feel called to leave a review, Spotify and Apple both take reviews of the podcast and they really help, you know, this kind of audio, this community, the episodes I share, reach more people. And if you think that might be useful for someone, maybe you don't, in which case, that's fine. Leave a review for another podcast you really love because I promise it will make someone stay. And have a beautiful week, beautiful weekend, wherever you are in the world, and thank you for listening. I'll see you next week.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、体能以及在我们奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的标志。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是2%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫能力的标志。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字的2%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄明白我们是怎么熬过来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? listening and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就需要这样做，请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个i-Heart播客，保证由人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。